today I wanna show you guys some new
cases that I just got from Razer and you
guys might know Razer as the gaming
company that has all kinds of crazy
accessories and computers and
microphones and headphones they even
have their own phone the Razer phone
which is mostly geared towards mobile
gaming but this is kind of exciting
because they now have iPhone cases and
what's great about these is they have
these little perforations for cooling
they have like a really soft little
inner lining to protect your phone from
scratching this is not sponsored by the
way but they did send me these to check
out and I wanted to make this video
because I'm a huge fan of Razer so
trying these cases out has been
something that I was really excited
about when I first saw that they
launched these so Thank You Razer I
can't wait to try these outs I also love
the look of it and I love that they have
a pink version obviously save three
different cases here they have a slim
version than a pro version the thin one
is obviously thinner so it's not rated
for a three meter drop like the thicker
pro version is okay so this one is made
for iPhone 11 Pro and the pink one I
have for the iPhone pro Max and the
white one for the iPhone 11 but they
sent three different versions in the
three different colors so this is the
one that has the certified drop
protection and as you guys know I had my
phone for not even an hour and I dropped
it and everyone thought that that video
was faked so yeah that video was real I
don't do drop tests and I never really
plan on doing them so that was something
that was not planned and it just so
happened ever look honestly just I was
in shock
so with this case you can tell that it
has protection all around it whereas a
lot of these cases the bottom is open to
a lot more access to the speakers this
is not a knife I'm just gonna use this
HDMI cable then to open this in there I
need a knife why do I can't have a knife
oh here we go
oh here it is look at this we've got the
lovely green razor accent this will
actually look pretty good I think around
the green iPhone look at that so the
green kind of peeks through the little
perforations so this is a nice little
soft cloth which is good because that'll
protect your phone from getting
scratched so that's what the first case
looks like this is the arktech pro just
seeing what it would feel like if it
fell again this is a little thicker of a
case as opposed to the slim ones so
we're gonna check out now I'm not gonna
test it next up is this is the pink one
so this is the arktech slim and this is
for the pro version oh my gosh this is
everything I like the look on the cover
but oh my gosh I'm just so excited I
don't like being a stereotypical girl
that likes pink but I am so sorry no I'm
not gonna apologize for what I like I
like what I like and if you don't like
it I don't think I have to apologize
this is what I like we're gonna try it
out so this also has the open bottom but
I get it because you are trying to have
a slimmer case that makes so much easier
to put your phone into this probably
would also look really good with the
white case but because this has this
little gray around there it kind of
pulls in the white from the white phone
okay so I might have found my new case
the dumb being not just my whole outfit
in my fingernails which I need to get
this pink off because I kind of sick of
it at this boy here's the pink with the
perforations I like the box is even all
pink so in the back here it says it has
a thermo Fein layer so that improves
performance and battery life for smart
phones which makes sense because if your
phone is getting really hot or
overheating if you're doing a lot of
processor intensive things that also
tends to suck the battery life out of
your phones so having something that
will help with cooling definitely make
sense vented channels for increased air
flow wireless charging compatibility now
we're on to the white this is also the
slim versions this is for the iPhone 11
I kind of might want to do the white
though my white phone so this is the
purple that's the - but my gosh
I think this white will look so good on
the white phone the purple actually
looks pretty good with the gray I like
that the access to the buttons is easy
because sometimes when you have a case
that covers of the buttons it sometimes
is harder to push I mean it's usually
not that much more difficult but if
you're taking like a photo or you're
using this top volume button to take
photos that a little bit more of
difficulty to press will give you a
little bit more shake when you're taking
the photo so this one obviously has the
buttons covered because this one is
certified for drought protection but
what I do like about this is when you
push the buttons they're very responsive
so these are some really cool case
options I'm excited to try this out I
think this is gonna be my new case for
the time being
honestly I'll probably be waiting for
Apple to release their battery charging
case because even though this battery
life is extended the amount that I use
my phone and what I put it through I
really love having the extra battery
case because even though I know my phone
can make it throughout the whole day I
love having that extra just reassurance
of knowing that I don't have to bring an
extra battery charger with me because I
have one already built into my phone so
guys those are the new cases from Razer
let me know what you think I think
they're pretty cool looking I'm working
on an iPhone 11 accessory roundup so
look for that soon I was there's so many
things out already there's a lot of
things that are like some knockoff
things that I've ordered I was like this
is garbage like I can't even show this
to you know if I do show it to you I'm
gonna feel bad cuz I'm gonna basically
say don't buy this but maybe that's the
information that you need well I'll see
you guys in my next video let me know if
there's anything else you would like to
see me cover here on my channel whether
it be iPhone related tech related food
related doesn't matter I'm here for you
guys and I look forward to seeing you in
my next video bye
seeing you but you're also seeing me
[Music]